العهد السعودي الامير محمد بن سلمان مع
وفد المكتب الدولي للمعارض ملف السعوديه
لاستضافه معرض الرياض اكسبو 2030 وذلك
خلال استقباله رئيس المكتب الدولي للمعارض
والوفد المرافقه له في العاصمه الرياض
وقبل ذلك عقدت بعثه المكتب الدولي للمعارض
اولى ورش العمل لتقييم ملف السعوديه
لاستضافه مع الدوليه 2030 في مدينه الرياض
ضمن اجراءات المكتب لتحديد الدوله
المستضيفه
خلال ورشه العمل الاولى استعراض مقومات
لترشح مدينه الرياض لاستضافه المعهد
والقيمه المضافه التي ستقدمها نسخه المعرض
في حال اختيار الرياض لاستضافتها
تفاصيل اكثر عن ملف اكسبورياض 2030 مع
العنود العبدلي نتابع
اكس
شاق وصعب هذا ما تدركه الرياض جيدا مع
العمل المستمر والمكثفه على ملف الاستضافه
وسط منافسه من اربع مدن عالميه هي موسكو
في روسيا ومدينه بوسان الكوريه الجنوبيه
ومدينه روما الايطاليه واخيرا مدينه اديسا
في اوكرانيا المدن الاربعه ستنافس العاصمه
السعوديه الرياض على الفوز باستضافه اكسبو
على ماذا تراهن الرياض ولي العهد السعودي
الامير محمد بن سلمان اكد التزام الرياض
بتقديم تجربه عالميه غير مسبوقه وهذا
اعلان السعوديه ووعدها لترشح استضافه او
لترشيح استضافه الرياض لمعرض اكسبو الدولي
اكتوبر 2030 هو موعد انطلاق المعرض الدولي
اكسبو ويستمر حتى ابريل من العام 2021
دعونا الان مشاهدينا نتعرف اكثر على ملف
الرياض لاستضافه هذا الحدث
اختار الفريق المعني بالملف موقعا مميزا
لمعرض اكسبو في شمال مدينه الرياض يمتد
هذا الموقع على مساحه سته ملايين متر مربع
ويقع على بعد اقل من عشر دقائق من مطار
الملك خالد الدولي ومن المتوقع ايضا
مشاهدينا تسجيل اربعين مليون زائر لموقع
المعرض في حال فوز الرياض بالاستضافه
اضافه الى حضور
226 مشاركا ضمن اجنحه دوليه ومنظمات
عالميه ومشاركين غير رسميين التطور
التكنولوجي مشاهدينا وتاثيرات التغير
المناخي والازدهار للجميع تعبر عن مرتكزات
استضافه الرياض الحدث الذي تسعى من خلاله
الى تعزيز الحلول المستدامه والمرونه في
التحولات التي اشهدها العالم تتقدم الرياض
مشاهدينا بشكل سريع في قائمه المدن الاكثر
زياره في العالم سياحيا وكذلك ثقافيا من
خلال المواقع المتعدده
وسياسه التاشيرات المفتوحه ما يجعلها
جاهزه لاستضافه العالم
من رياض مراسل العربيه عبد المحسن الحربي
عبد المحسن مرحبا بك هل هناك اي معلومات
اضافيه ايضا عن عمل وفد المكتب الدولي
للمعرض هذا اليوم
نعم خالد بالفعل بدا هذا الوفد المكون من
المكتب الدولي للمعارض للقيام باعماله
وتحديدا ورش العمل واللقاءات التي بداها
منذ يوم الامس وستستمر حتى يوم الجمعه
القادم الجدول الزيارات حافل ومليء
باللقاءات بالمسؤولين والوزراء وكذلك كافه
الضلعين في هذا الملف سواء كان من كافه
القطاعات نحن نتحدث عن ان الوفد يركز على
ابرز مقومات المدينه من مختلف انحائي
المدينه تحدث عن قطاع النقل سيلتقي وسيزور
مترو الرياض ومشروع الحافلات وايضا عن
القطاعات الاخرى بنظام الفندقه وكافه
المقومات الاخرى لمدينه التي سيقوم بعمل
زيارات كبيره جدا خلال الايام القليله
القادمه في جدول
اعماله من ثم سيتم عقد مؤتمر صحفي في
نهايه زياره هذا الوفد يوم الجمعه مع
الرئيس التنفيذي لهنايا الملكيه لمدينه
الرياض في نهايه هذه الجوله من ثم من مقرر
ايضا سيكون هناك زيارات اخرى لهذا الوفد
للدول الاخرى المرشحه وسيتم الاعلان عن
الترشيح الملف في مايو القادم بعد ما
يقارب شهرين من الان خالد متوقع ان يتم
ترشيح رسميا هذه الزيارات التي يقومون بها
في السعوديه وفي الدول المنافسه يتحدث عن
الدول الاخرى من ثم بعد ذلك تبدا عمليه
التصويت في نوفمبر القادم وهي عمليه تصويت
سريه من الدول الاعضاء في هذا في هذا في
هذه المنظمه وفي الحقيقه كان هنالك عمل
دبلوماسي كبير جدا للسعوديه خلال السنتين
الماضيه